being on TV has changed my life because
I get lots of free stuff if you like
being on TV it's fun and its really
inspiring to me that so many Armenian
girls watch the show and like what they
see and want to dress like me and my
sister is my favorite part of Armenian
culture is definitely the food and I
have brought all my friends from Beverly
Hills to the Armenian restaurant that I
go to and now they're all folks my
personal style is I'd say definitely
very sexy but I don't want to know what
I wear I think I like type things but I
like to either top card or the auto part
it can't do everything you want I would
love to be remembered as someone that is
very stylish probably different than
what you know my perception is now
that's kind of why I'm really excited
for my show - Ian I know that by
instead of all these stereotypes but I'm
a cop from the rescue me to me there you
go
there are so many misconceptions about
me plastic surgery rumors to people and
dated none of it's true
I think that I'm famous for probably you
know I don't know Hollywood girl thing
is kind of different than
that's a tough question but if I were to
choose my perfect ideal guy would be
someone that's not too tall but not too
short definitely built but not like -
not just one it's very funny
my ultimate goal where I see myself in
five ten years
married happily married listen kids
[Music]
[Music]